hi everybody thank you for watching my
talk this is going to be all about
parallel processing in python really
all about the landscape of tools that
exist today for parallel distributed
cluster computing
all of those things things are moving
really really quickly these days
so hopefully i can at least catch you up
on where we are now but then likely this
talk is going to be out of date in six
months so
i'm not going to go super in-depth on
any tool but i'll be giving links and
some
some resources so if you want to grab
the slides you can kind of follow along
there and click on the links
and then one thing i'll say is that all
the opinions that i kind of talk about
of these different tools are
my own my name is erin i work for saturn
cloud and really my job there is to
ensure that data scientists can
do their work in the fastest way
possible using the best tools
either the tools that they kind of
already know and love or help them along
with tools that they don't already don't
yet know
um and i actually gave a talk
at pi data miami in 2019 that feels like
forever ago and it's funny because that
talk was actually all about how your
data fits in ram and you don't need
cluster computing
so i had done a lot of work in the past
with spark more from the data
engineering side and then i kind of
always did my machine learning and data
science in the pi data ecosystem like
scikit-learn and pandas and such
and i was talking all about there how
you can really take advantage of your
laptop but then also do kind of
parallel processing just on your single
machine and this
feels like a natural kind of evolution
onto ways
onto like when you actually need cluster
computing what are the right tools to
choose for that job
so i work for saturn cloud full
disclosure we are
we are a commercial offering center
around a couple of the tools that i'm
going to be talking about
uh in my talk so i'm going to try to
give like kind of an unbiased and fair
shake of the stuff but
inevitably it's going to be a little bit
biased and kind of all of these kinds of
talks are
a little bit biased anyway i'm just
telling you what my bias is
um so saturn cloud itself is an
end-to-end data science and machine
learning platform on the cloud
we just make it easy for data science
teams and data scientists to kind of get
going in
python and then get going scaling to
clusters with desk and
gpus with rapids and things like that
so first this is just like why do we
need parallel computing right
we have this great awesome pi data stack
where we can do a lot of things but a
lot of these tools were historically
built for single core
uh in memory type work and that's really
where a lot of these challenges come
from
so like you know if you're ready to kind
of analyze your data and get going um
you know you can use those tools fairly
well um and
if you've seen it in my talks before i
am reusing the memes here so apologies
it's kind of hard to find
good memes these days you know but
anyway you might run out of memory
right that's the first thing it's like
okay well now i need a cluster i need a
bigger machine because i'm out of memory
or if you do get enough memory your
computing just takes forever
um and then you're either stuck waiting
or now you have to find another solution
and then you end up feeling like this so
the entire idea is that
from my talk is so that you don't feel
like this and you feel empowered
to choose the right tool for what you
might need to do
so when would you need parallel
processing similar to what we just went
through is when you have a lot of data
or you have a lot of computations that
you need to run or both
so i do want to caveat this and this
relates a little bit to my previous
party to miami talk is that
you shouldn't do cluster computing or
parallel computing unless you have to
if everything works just fine on your
laptop in pandas numpy and that kind of
world
stay there there's no reason to learn
something else if you start to hit
boundary if you start to kind of hit the
walls of that
um you can actually use most of these
tools that i'm talking about today
on your laptop or on a single machine
it's a lot less infrastructure to manage
than a cluster
same way you can kind of bump that up to
a pretty big machine in the cloud
still on a single machine and then
really when you need to take advantage
of a lot of resources you can then do a
cluster
on the cloud and then you can kind of
mix and match depending on specific
workloads you can do it on a cluster
here and do it on a single machine there
so this is really what we're talking
about and try to say this five times
fast
python packages for parallel processing
i can barely even say it
uh but that's what we're going through
today uh a few different packages
i'll start with just kind of giving you
an overview of the land in the world
that we're kind of coming from
is again we're starting from this kind
of pi data single machine type work
these are just kind of representative
packages for the types of workloads you
might do so data frames arrays
machine learning and deep learning not
an exhaustive list
but kind of in parallel there's this
other world that has been built up over
the last 10
20 years is this kind of big data world
that was really more of like
data engineers etl type jobs
that kind of came out of the hadoop
ecosystem so there's a few tools there
we're really not going to focus on a lot
of them except for spark
but the idea is now that these two
worlds are coalescing where we need
scientific computing like an intense
data science stuff
on large amounts of data so we're kind
of putting these two things together
and that's where some of the tools that
i'm talking about uh fit in
we're gonna focus specifically on these
three tools spark ray and das
for like the parallel computing and i'm
going to give you the stories on each of
them and kind of compare and contrast
on the bottom row here rapids mode in vx
and mars they're kind of
some honorable mentions i'm going to
talk a lot about rapids because it's
actually very relevant
with these tools but in itself it's not
technically a parallel computing tool
um and then mode nvx i'll mention real
quick
a mars is something that's super super
new i'm not even really going to focus
on but at least wanted to
throw the logo on there to show that
there's like a lot of players
in this space but hopefully we can kind
of simplify that here
so when it comes to actually choosing
the tool and really this is especially
when you're
choosing this for like enterprise
adoption there's a lot of considerations
when you're picking an open source
project there are all these things you
might want to know because it'll help
inform
the type of experience you might get
when you're using these tools so
um here are all the points i'm not going
to talk about each of them because i'm
going to have a slide kind of dedicated
to them
but basically it's like why was it too
created what community was it created
for
how popular is it now how well
maintained is it
how can you kind of dive into the tool
itself and check out the code
and then the hardest part with a lot of
this is really the deployment piece
when you have to deal with clusters and
machines and infrastructure and all that
stuff
and that's where commercial offerings a
lot of the times come in they do manage
services
and then we'll i'll kind of introduce
all of these tools individually for
these considerations and i'm going to
flip it
and i'm going to go based on workload or
capabilities so i'll say
data frames what's available arrays
what's available machine learning deep
learning
that kind of stuff and it's all about
what's built into the tool directly and
then what kind of ecosystem is built
around the tool
to enable a lot of different workloads
because again that helps show like how
mature and how stable the tool itself is
so i took a few of these points uh from
this talk from a pilot in new york city
last year from eric dill
and he gave a great talk kind of doing
something similar
specifically for spark versus desk and
rapid so i'm kind of pulling
in right here i'm pulling in some of my
own opinions and then also giving it a
quick update because
that talk was a year ago so again this
makes the space moves really fast so
it's a bit outdated now
okay spark um basically spark again was
born out of the hadoop ecosystem in that
hadoop world
it's a distributed computing platform
based on the concept of mapreduce
and it was again created for like large
scale analytics etl things that data
engineers
would do and it's the oldest tool that
we're talking about
um here when it comes to desk
desk is a again distributed computing
tool these all are
but it's based on task scheduling of
low-level task scheduling so it's a
different paradigm
than mapreduce where you kind of map
over a list and then kind of reduce
individually
this is actually parallelizing
individual units of work
and the reason this was created was
specifically to scale
python code and python packages it was
born and created at anaconda
specifically so that you can ex so that
people could accelerate python packages
so
that community that's been built up
around it you'll see the difference
there
um so specifically for python
ray is here actually came out of the
same research lab that created spark
i think they changed names but it's the
same lab a lot of some of the same
professors and people involved
um the low level kind of task paradigm
is very similar to dasc
it introduced the concept of actors
which i'll get into
but desk and ray there's actually this
thread on github where the the creators
will actually talk about the differences
the main things might were that actor
thing
and then just some nuances of how the
task scheduling works for each of these
tools
but i believe that rey was originally
and initially built for like
distributing deep learning applications
and i put that in a question mark only
because i am the least familiar with rey
of all these tools
just letting you know because i think
i've been the deep learning is the
community i've been kind of less
connected to as opposed to like
data engineering spark and data science
with desk and things like that
okay so here's a slide of just all of
them so you can kind of see how the
logos and
see the whole story for all of them
i do need to mention one other tool and
that's rapids because
rapids itself the core of what rapids is
is pushing
data science workloads to the gpu so
it's packages it's packages for data
frames arrays
machine learning where now instead of
executing on cpus like all the other
packages do
it'll actually execute way way faster on
a gpu and it's really exciting so i
would definitely check out rapids
it's a cool package it's really
mind-blowing some of the performance
speed ups you get
um it's newer it's created at nvidia it
is an open source project and there's a
large dev team support from nvidia
but the key here when we're talking
about parallel computing is that das
has a native i'm sorry rapids has a
native das integration to actually
execute on multiple gpus because
gpus have a lot less ram than main
memory so you need to kind of scale out
when your data gets bigger
but it integrates really well with the
python ecosystem it's it's one of those
consequences of das
being python native and built for python
it was kind of the inevitable
choice to scale rapids so when i'm
talking about dasc
think about rapids is kind of coming
alongside with desk as well in a lot of
these places
[Music]
if you want more about desk another pi
data talk keith cross is
one of the maintainers of rapids uh
specifically the data frame package i
believe
um and he gave an awesome talk on just
like all things rapids if you don't know
anything about it
watch this talk you'll be convinced the
gpus are the future and you'll be
convinced that
uh rapids is a great package and desk
with it is is good too
and but again it's already outdated so
there's a lot of new developments that
have happened in the last year but i'm
not going to focus a lot on that on
rapids
specifically so when it comes to
languages i took these screenshots
straight from the github
repos of all these projects but the main
idea here is that spark was built in
scala it's a jvm language so
that kind of like reflects itself and
when you get errors and that you get
these kind of weird java stack traces
and when you're trying to debug it or
when you try to
contribute to it you're going to have to
write in scala so given this is a
pi data python audience i'm assuming
that might be kind of a big hurdle for a
lot of people here
to ask you can see here is 100 or 99.9
i don't know what the other point one is
python built in python
api for python array its main api
is python and it integrates with a lot
of the python packages there is some
code there kind of built in c
plus and some other things so might be a
little bit more kind of
hurdle to contribute if you want to
popularity so i don't want to look at
github stars but i don't think that's
the best metric
um so when i think of like how popular
is a person
i'll go check their twitter or their
instagram how many followers do they
have so maybe the same thing works for
open source python packages i don't know
well
um so spark here has like 30 000
followers again it's the oldest tool you
see that this account was created four
years before desk
desk has around 6000 and ray has like
1400 so that kind of gives you some
relative idea of popularity maybe but i
have a better
more scientific metric here which is pi
pi stats so this is
pip install package like how many times
does that happen so it doesn't
necessarily mean
a net new user or a specific individual
it probably means more of automated jobs
doing pip installs like daily or
on some other schedule but it still
gives a good relative comparison of how
popular tool
the tool is because if a tool is kind of
being used daily for a job that's always
pip installing then
it's probably being used a lot and it's
probably popular so
spark here has the most at seven million
desk at almost one and a half and then
raise
uh there at two hundred thousand so this
is as of october 2020 but hopefully that
gives you again
like a relative idea of the popularity
[Music]
um and then spark and dash specifically
were part of the python developer survey
in 2019 that jetbrains did
and this is of all python users so not
even just data science like web devops
like all python users
thirteen percent of them said they use
spark and then five percent of them said
they use desk which
shows that there's like a big group of
people actually using these tools like
five percent of all python users using
desk
is like a good significant number array
wasn't on the survey probably again
because it's like newer and not as
popular
maybe it'll be in a future one
okay so as far as native capabilities
there's there's a lot here
going on but the idea is like you know
if there's a specific meaning that you
do
and that you focus on or like a handful
of them this list might give you a good
idea of like which tool might be the
right thing to choose so
for spark i say the most popular
capabilities of spark are the data
frames in sql and then
i think some people use the machine
learning i kind of recommend not to
um and then dask is all the way from
like low level
task parallelization you can parallelize
just like arbitrary code
all the way up to data frames arrays uh
and machine learning
and then ray you can kind of see the
difference on the different
kind of applications that rey has been
focused on is really all a lot around
deep learning
reinforcement learning distributing deep
learning training
model serving and things like that and
then the kind of custom api
is similar again to desk where you can
do individual tasks and then it
introduced this kind of
actors api and so the native
capabilities can be a little bit fuzzy
because again when it comes to like the
ecosystem
things can be built on top of these
tools and built with them and i think
that's really
even a more compelling type of thing to
look at so here's the ecosystem
spark itself is mostly an all-in-one
package all-in-one tool part of
partially because of the way that it was
built is kind of internals
and partially just kind of that's how
it's been um they have
been doing some work to kind of pull in
more pi data workloads and kind of
python support
into spark but it does feel a little
bolted on like in
easier to find functions and kind of
like extraneous packages and i think
even the
extra boost had to be forked for it to
work properly um
so it doesn't have really a lot of
ecosystem the same way that like pi data
normally does with a lot of packages
interacting
das definitely has the biggest ecosystem
here because it was built
specifically to support parallelization
for a lot of packages so
like rapids and scikit-learn and like a
bunch of other tools and
and what's with especially with desk is
tools were built like
specifically like where their core
functionality is built
with desk tools like rapids and prefect
um or
an x-ray or like desk is really really
core to how that tool works and
its parallelization ray you'll see here
like
tensorflow are big ones again because of
the deep learning and then like a couple
other tools it's it's
integrations are newer actually this
link if you click on it and you look at
some of the github pages for those
integrations they're almost
some of them are just like a week or a
few days old and that kind of shows how
quickly
rey is moving and like some of the new
stuff that's happening right now but it
is still really new and i think not as
mature of an ecosystem
desk is listed there and the desk and
ray integration is specifically
for doing using raise scheduler to
schedule task tasks
um that's pretty much it i'm not sure
that anybody uses that and i'm not sure
of the benefits of it i haven't been
able to use that myself so i can't
really speak to it
[Music]
okay so when it comes to deployment like
i said this is the hardest
thing generally with these tools um but
it kind of the options kind of reflect
again when they were born so like spark
hadoop and yarn
spark was born out of hadoop and so
that's kind of one of the main
deployment options
whereas with das it was built to support
a lot of different workloads and a lot
of like scientific and academic stuff
so there's like hpc support there but
then also like
native cloud integrations where you can
just put in your aws credentials and
then like run a script and then it'll
launch a dash cluster
and then ray again being newer and being
more cloud focused
most of their deployment options are
like strictly just straight cloud
but then like what about the pain factor
right so it's not just like how can you
deploy but like how hard is it to manage
and all that stuff um with spark there's
like a lot of more things to get working
a lot more
configuration you have to do a lot more
knobs you have to tweak uh desk is pure
python again so that might be a little
bit easier to work with
um and then ray i don't have a lot of
information share on that because i
haven't done like a whole lot of
deployment
with ray but it seems like the code that
they built in there is kind of made for
easy deployments
but this is where kind of commercial
offerings really come to the
conversation because deployment's hard
so then companies are out here
giving you managed services for these
tools when it comes to spark there are a
lot of managed services out there
databricks is probably one of the
leading ones where they kind of have
like
easy to easy to manage spark clusters
you can kind of launch them and run your
spark code clouds themselves also have
native hadoop and spark offerings that i
think a lot of people use i've used emr
and data breaks both
myself um and you know microsoft and
google
have offerings there um das is was
originally again born out of anaconda so
there's a support
perspective from there but anaconda
doesn't do any like managed
desk um what's cool is that within the
last year or two
there's now packages or i'm sorry now
companies out here to do managed
desk clusters so one of them is the
company that i work for saturn cloud
and quality as well does that uh ray the
only company really in the space of ray
right now is any scale
i think they just opened up a private
beta like a week or two ago
like really recently um and they seem to
be driving forward a lot of like the ray
road map
and all those things but the main
takeaway from this slide is that spark
is mature has a lot of offerings
das is picking up a lot of traction
commercially which is which is a great
sign
and which means that there's like a lot
of there's options now and there's like
support and you know that like companies
are
really caring about it and it feels a
lot like the beginning of like the
hadoop world when companies like
cloudera and hortonworks and such came
out
and then ray has like any scale kind of
pushing it forward right now
but it is still like the newest okay so
we're going to take a quick breather
here
because i know i threw a lot of
information at you um so hopefully you
can digest some of that look at the
slides and then we're going to pivot
this now
we're going to look at capabilities and
workloads and then what tools might be
the best things to choose
for these different workloads okay
capabilities the ones we're specifically
going to focus on are these
specific these are really like data
science and machine learning focused
type workloads and i'll talk about all
of these different ones
so arrays is probably the the simplest
choice or the easiest kind of thing to
navigate because
if you're doing multi-dimensional arrays
and you need parallel computing for it
dasc is your choice that's the only like
definitive thing i'm going to say
in this whole presentation is that if
you need multi-dimensional arrays
use das it's really the only option out
there and it is a very good one
not just it's the only one and then a
with
koopa which is like a gpu enabled one
das integrates with that so you can do
like gpu accelerated
arrays with spark the way that it's
built it's just really not possible to
do multi-dimensional arrays
and ray it's probably technically
possible to like
customize something with the task
interface but it's probably more work
than it's worth
and so task is really the choice here
data frames is the opposite now
data frames is like the really really
complicated not complicated but really
really crowded
side of the parallel computing world we
have spark which
has its own data frame api it doesn't
mirror pandas and then the rest of these
tools
are really all kind of like mirroring
pandas or pandas based apis and things
like that
so das has a data frame which kind of
parallelizes pandas data frames and it
handles the orchestration there
koalas is a package that's a panda's
front end
for spark so all of your stuff that's
happening is executing on spark on a
spark cluster it's going to scala and
like all that stuff so you need a spark
cluster and everything
but you're writing code that looks like
pandas mode in
is similar except it's for a ray or a
das
backend so moden's goal is where you can
just switch your import pandas to import
mode in
and then it'll parallelize that to array
or dash cluster which you kind of
specify
vx here is like an honorable mention i
have an asterisk because it's not a
parallel computing tool
it's an out of core data frame tool so
but people mention it a lot when they're
talking about like accelerating data
frames so
vex is a way for you to analyze data
sets that are larger than fit into
memory
on your laptop or single machine but
it's not a parallel processing tool
and then rapids comes in for the gpu
accelerated data frames
and then you can parallelize that with
the native das integration and kind of
get a lot of speed ups
ibis here is a good thing to mention too
which is not pandas based it's a data
frame api that's more
sql kind of focused but it's meant to
have like
different interchangeable back ends so
like postgres or snowflake or anything
like that but your code is like
a data frame api um
so there's a lot of choices here right
um i think
my kind of recommendation is that your
data frame isn't necessarily the driving
choice for the tool
you kind of want to think about some of
the other things that you're doing like
the machine learning and scientific
computing
if you're only doing data frames and you
just have like a csv that's a little bit
bigger than your laptop
you have more flexibility you can kind
of choose whichever one you're more
comfortable with
but you really need to think about the
ecosystem and the other things that
you're going to do beyond the data
frames
when choosing a tool if you want to know
more about this whole data frame world
though
you can check out this talk from mark
garcia he's a pandas core developer in
ibis as well
he gave a great talk at a pi data meetup
just recently kind of
going more in depth to this whole kind
of messy data frame ecosystem
okay so so i said that your decision
should be driven
more by more than just data frames like
if you're doing a raise you're going to
want to ask
and then we'll talk here about machine
learning and deep learning specifically
so
machine learning there's more than just
training
a model on a giant data set
it's about like what are you actually
doing in that case so like a lot of the
times and
my last pi data talk was about this is a
lot of times you just can sample your
data set and use scikit-learn and you
should do that
if you can do that and it's accurate do
that there's no reason to like
use more data when it's not necessary so
and then if you have that trained model
when you're doing parallel computing
you're probably doing like parallel like
batch inference
or you're probably doing some sort of
hyper parameter tuning or ensembling and
that's when it gets
really interesting and that's when you
probably will need a lot of these tools
but there is
still the concept of distributed
training like in case you really do need
to use those large data sets and so
spark has a lot of algorithms
built in for distributed training um das
and rapids also do
and that's dasskin rapids have native
interoperability with scikit-learn so
you can use a scikit-learn pipeline
with a das ml model and that way you're
not kind of having to relearn again like
a new tool where a sparx ml
package is a completely new api that you
would have to learn
when it comes to batch inference these
all these tools can really do batch
inference because you're just wrapping
um model.predict in some sort of cluster
kind of
orchestration type thing so with dash
delayed or even like a spark udf or
something like that you can you can
pretty much get away with batch
inference pretty easily with all of
these tools
um but uh das does have like a native
parallel post fit class where you can
um like use passing your scikit-learn
model but then kind of
use that same api to do like batch
inference across the cluster hyper
parameter tuning is where this gets
really interesting is when you need to
train
a bunch of models maybe the data itself
is pretty small but you need to do
a lot of training ray dasc and rapids
all have
offerings around hyper parameter tuning
that you can kind of take a look at more
um and stay tuned i'm probably going to
be working on some sort of blog post
with saturn about like specifically like
which algorithms are available for
distributed training
versus hyper parameter tuning versus
batch inference
and we'll go into a lot more details
specifically on which tool
has which but as far as the distributed
training
spark and dash and rapids cover pretty
like very similar algorithms
whereas ray doesn't really have a lot of
distributed training specifically for
machine learning their focus is more on
deep learning like i'll show you
so so actually one thing that you'll see
in all of these tools
have a job lib back-end so what this
means is scikit-learn
has this api that uses job lib for
managing like parallel training so
scikit-learn does parallel training like
through a grid search
or random forest but built in it's just
on a single machine it'll use all the
cores in your machine
all of these tools dasgrain spark all
have interfaces for a jobless back-end
which will just take that training and
not paralyze it across your cluster
the key here though is that your data
has to still fit in memory of your
client machine it's not like a truly
distributed
training where you can kind of pull in
chunks of the data automatically and
then distribute from there because
you'll have to actually pull it through
scikit-learn and then it gets
distributed out so this is useful for
those like big compute scenarios
where you kind of just need to
distribute a lot of things like a random
forest
or like a grid search um that's kind of
how you would and here's just examples
of how you might do it
it's all very similar you just tell it a
different job that back in with the with
the context manager
[Music]
okay so when it comes to now tree
ensembles and this is
specifically like xgboost is mostly what
i'm focusing on and then as well light
gbm
xg boost has ways to parallelize model
training with all of these tools
uh spark it's a little clunkier i i
think this xg boost 4j spark package
i've tried to get it working with python
i haven't had a lot of success
our rapids as well has some stuff
integrated with spark to do extra boost
but
i think it's required some like private
forks to get it working so
it's not like a super native integration
um
desk itself actually the xg boost
package if you go to the xg boost
docs you'll see a section about how to
parallelize training with desk
specifically so
there's a really really tight native
integration there there is a dask light
gbm package and we at saturn actually
one of my colleagues there is actually
working specifically on putting that
natively into the light gpm package
where you can use das directly from
there
you can also do dash and rapids for the
gpu computing
like shown there which is again native
to the xg boost package so
dasc is really really tightly coupled
into that
ray has a super new package called
xgboostray
to do like the parallelization with rey
um
i again it's super news i haven't had a
chance to use it but maybe that's
something to watch out for if you're
interested in that
okay so when it comes to deep learning
here i think again ray i think was
initially built for a lot of this kind
of deep learning type work
so you'll see more of its high level
interfaces
focusing on that so like distributed
training with pytorch and tensorflow
hyperparameter tuning and reinforcement
learning you can kind of check
out those different libraries and see
how ray works with that
um desk the distributed like inference
is a pretty straightforward exercise
with desk we're actually working on a
blog post at saturn
uh to kind of illustrating that with
tensorflow or pi torch
um because you kind of just can wrap in
a delayed function
doing inference and training is also
possible there aren't
currently native integrations with
pytorch and tension flow for
das we are at saturn specifically
working on one
uh we're working on pi torch first um so
kind of
you know stay tuned on that we're
working on that kind of native
integration
but das does integrate from the more of
the inference hyper parameter tuning
side not the training
with um the kind of scikit-learn api
packages
around pytorch and tensorflow so scorch
and psycaris
if you use those tools it's actually
pretty straightforward and there's
desk docs for how to actually
parallelize across a cluster of gpus
that's probably mostly for
hyperparameter tuning or maybe inference
if you're using the scikit-learn
apis with these with these deep learning
tools
okay so that was a lot of stuff so i'm
hoping i at least gave you a little bit
of insight onto like
the different workloads and which tools
might use but then maybe
you know maybe you're like me when i go
to talk like this i want somebody to
just tell me what to choose like
just tell me which package i need to use
please like there's too many choices
well i'm not going to completely do that
i'm just going to kind of give you some
candid opinions
on each of the tools and hopefully that
can kind of help you and if you want to
kind of
talk about this more find me in gather
town or like
hit me up on twitter or something and we
can chat more about this
so uh first spark i'm just gonna kind of
give you my opinions
i think if you're doing stuff like
already in spark
in the kind of just data engineering
world of
mostly sql-esque type work and
transformations
and you're not really doing a lot of
machine learning you're not doing a lot
of data science
specifically spark is probably still
like a good choice for that if you're
if you're doing that especially if you
already use it it can be challenging
with debugging scala
um and cluster management and deployment
so those are still reasons that i would
think even if you're only doing that
stuff you might want to consider another
tool
um but if you're doing like a lot of
machine learning
if you're doing deep learning scientific
computing if you have a lot of code
already written in the pi data ecosystem
spark is probably not the best choice
for that because you're going to have to
rewrite a lot of your stuff you're going
to have to deal with the jvm
and probably some things that you might
want to do won't even be possible
okay so desk um if you don't even like
want to believe me there's a
there's a great desk article about
really like why an institution
should adopt ask and the scenarios and
the reasons to do that
there's a really great article if you
want to read that
why you would use it is because of its
large ecosystem of packages
because it's python native it's built
for
data science machine learning scientific
computing
like i mentioned if you're doing
multi-dimensional arrays and you need to
scale them
you're going to want to use das x-ray is
like a fantastic and awesome package
in that world but it also has a super
flexible low-level api for you to just
parallelize kind of arbitrary python
code
and that's the core of what desk is
and there's a lot of deployment options
from like just desk itself
on hpc or clouds or different things and
there's commercial support for that too
reasons that you might not use desk
maybe if all of your work is like pure
sql type transformations um you might be
better off using another tool
and then maybe not even spark in that
case you might be better off using like
a database like snowflake or
some other type of like pure sql uh work
so ray so why rey i'd say rey was built
up
a lot for a lot of deep learning
features um so if that's
like if that's all that you do and like
all that you're interested in for
cluster computing
ray might be something that you would
want to look at um
and the low level api like if you really
want like a low level actor api
you can use ray um otherwise the task
api again is like really similar to desk
and desk i think still has like a bigger
ecosystem
um and why would you not use ray i think
just because it's still
pretty new like there is a lot of
momentum that like any scale is bringing
a lot around it and a lot of stuff
happening um
there's still only like one commercial
player which means that you know they're
kind of only driving all of rey
um and so it's just like newer um and if
that's something where you're kind of
fine with you want to kind of like play
around with it and try it you can
definitely check it out
but um again i'm a little biased i'm
probably going to recommend desk for a
lot of your workloads
so would you use more than one that
might be a question to think about when
you're thinking about all these tools
um i would say you're probably not going
to use more than one in the same script
or the same job
you could technically use more than one
in the same cluster
because like if like with yarn or
something they kind of all support yarn
or maybe
but or like a cloud provider i don't
think there's really a reason to
like run desk and spark or desk and rain
and all those things on the same
cluster but across an enterprise i could
see potentially
uh like an organization using more than
one tool like if they have a lot of data
engineering already built up in spark
but they now need to parallelize a lot
of their data science they might use
desk or like deep learning stuff
with ray um again i i think the most
flexible option for like smaller teams
and organizations that kind of need to
do a ride for a wide variety of work
uh is desk and then really if you want
to do like gpu acceleration with rapids
desk is really your choice um because
that has really the best
uh integration with it there
and that's it um so again thank you for
watching i know i threw a lot of
information
at you so if you want a little bit you
know talk a little bit more chat a
little bit more you have specific
workloads that you're thinking about you
need to parallelize
i would love to talk with you if you
find me in gathered town or
send me an email find me on twitter we
also do have a
slack community for saturn cloud so you
can kind of jump in there
find me or like just post on the chat
it's you know open community talking
about all things python and parallel
computing and everything
i mean if you do want to try saturn
cloud if like you're really kind of
convinced about desk and rapids
we have like a free hosted oh we have a
hosted product where you can get a free
trial on there and it's kind of just
like a pay as you go thing
you don't even have to install it in any
of your clouds or anything like that
or if you need an enterprise solution we
do have one that you can install
into your kind of cloud account but um
again thank you for watching i hope this
didn't create more
confusion it might have but hopefully at
least you are now familiar with the
names of the packages
what they do what they don't do and then
that'll help drive your future research
and adoption but again reach out if you
have any questions
thank you